I mean dude David did you read I mean
did you ever think you'd be standing in
your own pizza shop yeah yeah you did
well since I was a kid no no dream
though we designed this specific one
like about a year and a half ago and I
was like I hope it looks somewhat cool
but it looks exactly like to the teeth
how you imagine yeah it's like we like
built it like in a video game and like
exactly came to life so like when we
first saw it I was blown away and I want
to give this right because Snapchat
recently named you one of the platforms
most hell yeah creators right and on
Tick Tock you got 27 million followers
how does it feel to be able to kind of
expand the content you're doing there
because I know we miss you on YouTube oh
it's so cool Snapchat is just like the
best because I can literally like go
about my regular day and just do regular
things and it's a lot like toned down
whereas I post like YouTube like you're
always trying to make sure something's
funny and like your editing and Snapchat
is just like you can be more organic I
use my hands a lot when I talk me too
that's crazy me too no but really though
I think people forget that when you're
creating content in YouTube videos like
that that takes a lot of time yeah so I
feel like taking that step back must
have opened you and getting your
opportunity to focus on things like this
totally 100 there's no way if I was
making videos we'd be able to make this
there's no way because yeah you know
obviously I wasn't in the kitchen
cooking myself every day but I was
trying every single slice that ever came
out from Alan and me and making them and
that's just the food there's also the
business partner there's so much of it
that like yeah and it's and it took so
many so many so many hours and so many
people and like I'm just so proud of
everybody here I'm really stoked do you
miss YouTube at all or making videos
yeah of course yeah but like I want to
try the pizza right the goal would be to
have our next location like somewhere in
Chicago and then San Diego Miami New
York and like that would be the dream
obviously I was gonna ask you what the
next era of David dobrik looks like is
it tall Pizza it's all pizza and then
pasta there it is what inspired you to
kind of like enter the pizza business I
think it goes back to like creating a
fun experience I think Pizza is like the
most universally loved thing and just
like creating a place where like people
can come hang out and have a good time
like one of my favorite things I always
reference is like the basement in That
70s Show like where everyone just comes
in and they can like go in as they
please yeah and like now I finally have
a place like that but for the public you
guys can't smell it but it smells good
in here I mean it smells really good
pizza but it's also a little deep those
are air fresheners yeah is that what it
is I don't know he it's like Abercrombie
you're just spraying this every 20
minutes the pizza doesn't actually smell
good no it smells awesome in here but
also the little details like the D and
the bee on the door like what was the
thing that you had to have in this shop
um my favorite part like I think
everything that's great needs like a
little gimmick one of our like little
gimmicks is the party time button so
with each Pizza you get a little coin
and you either use it for a free scoop
of ice cream we have an ice cream window
or you can put it in the slot and this
place turns into a little disco yeah 10
to 15 seconds okay I love that okay so
it's a party here at doughbridge Pizza
it's kind of about the experience like
my dream is my dream is to one day own a
hotel so like I feel like this is the
first like baby step to creating a fun
experience awesome I'm so so for you
obviously you're from Chicago suburbs
what's up don't say this on that yeah
but everybody I meet I say Chicago right
until they're also from Chicago now I go
I mean suburbs in the air you're a lot
closer than I am right from China Town
right right which is of course known for
its deep dish pizza so I'm curious like
what is the dough like here what's the
crust what do you offering people it's
not necessarily deep dish but the most
Chicago thing here is our Tavern styles
are thin it's like really cracker thin
okay and then this is a more of like a
focaccia bread like heavier pizza so
it's this is our doughy so it's known
for its dough you know it's gooey you
can see the crust just kind of like that
looks crunchy right now it looks really
good so good I think these are fake I
don't even think no they're real trust
me I smell them they're real they're a
real deal how long did it take to bring
this Vision to life I hate saying it
because it sounds like I'm making it up
but like three years which is that
sounds like a long time too because I
know a lot of influencers and stuff
they'll be like I've been working on
this forever but this actually feels
like one of those things that like I've
been working on for so long I remember
every month I'd be like it's never
opening right it's like not happening
right right and like now we're here are
you nervous at all so nervous really
yeah because because now everybody's a
Critic so it's like everybody comes in
tick tocks it the sauce is wrong the
cheese is wrong that day or whatever
like I'm so confident everybody that's
come by has like absolutely loved it and
I've read their text messages from other
people that have also tried it and like
talking behind my back so positively
about it so I'm like okay this is this
is legit I think people are really
liking it you're right I'm gonna have to
try an actual Joe bricks pizza slice but
I also want to make I want to help you
okay you're gonna have a line out the
door dude let's do it let's do it come
on back these look good okay these are
two of my literal favorites I think okay
this is the pepperoni and has honey on
it honey is kind of what makes this
thing the most amazing and this is spicy
vodka so like what you'd find on like
pasta if you're familiar this looks so
good I got my pizza cutter here yeah I
mean I don't know if I trust myself
there's only one way to find out
oh pepperonis are flying that's how I
like my pizza are we racing
and I was kind of going fast there
wasn't I said I was like let me beat him
I'm actually doing too bad here sir just
so you know I can't wait to try this
okay which one do you want you wanna try
that first go for this one okay that's a
good size nice good eye right all right
here we go
okay don't just hype it up to the camera
so do your thing enjoy it
um
I'm not hyping up for the camera man
this is effing good oh wow I almost
crushed really legit wow that sauce and
pepperoni wow it's so good hold on let
me go that's gonna cost ET ten thousand
dollars right there that's where I will
slip yeah that was real wow that is Bomb
oh my God thank you two thumbs up for me
okay well then try this one that's
really exciting man that's good oh this
is the Vodka that one's good yeah so
it's a little different flavor so it's
taking a good breakfast look at that
crust right there okay the little air
bubbles too
look I sound like I'm a chef
dude pepperoni is usually my go-to
but this is next level yeah yeah the
crunchiness
this is good for Alan and Ian these guys
are the ones you guys can you guys come
in here you honestly crushed it I mean
these guys made the whole thing possible
I don't even know how did you guys do
this magic little magic well it was
magic and it was a lot of me complaining
right and then I'd be like no David this
is how you actually I don't know what
you guys did but the potion you nailed
it okay in fact I'm gonna go I'm gonna
get another bite of this magic every
time they'd come out with a new pizza
I'd have a note and they'd be like I
don't think that's the correct note and
I'd be like you're right really and then
that's how we got here I knew I was
trusting them these two are my favorite
and then Tavern style is a whole
different thing too different kind of
and Hawaiian pizza but I don't want to
get through political here but I do love
Hawaiian let me ask you this what do you
want fans to know about dough breaks
Pizza like what sets this pizza apart
from the other spots well I think I
think there's I think the honey and the
vodka and the crust itself is so
different but I think people really need
to come out and try it because I know
that you know I know an influencer
owning a business is like what is this
is this real but like this pizza this is
this is the one I would order yes if I
didn't on this place so this is I'm
telling you just come out and try it and
then make your judgments I I know you'll
love it take it from me
it slaps okay it really really does in
fact yeah can I go can I do this oh it's
never been time yeah I'm combining both
is that right wow now we have eight
different pizzas wait literally listen
I'm moving in here I live here now but
you like them yeah okay really good it's
bleeping good it's bleeping good you
know there's only one thing left to do
here right yes oh yeah it's a party can
I get a token or here you go you've
earned I feel like I earned this right
and
yeah
[Music]